another state experiencing a very
worrying surge is Florida which reported
more than 18,000 new cases over the
weekend alone local leaders blame
irresponsible people who defy the rules
and the guidelines Manuel Bojorquez
reports from Miami Beach Miami mayor
Francis Juarez says all options are on
the table including another stay at home
order as a city races to contain a surge
in coronavirus cases and for anyone who
says but the death rate is so much lower
now he would say concerns over
irresponsible behavior led officials in
Miami Dade and Broward counties to close
the beaches over the fourth of July
weekend hospitalizations are up more
than 50% in miami-dade County from last
week and the 14-day average rate of
positive tests is more than 16 percent
statewide the rate of positivity is
roughly 12 percent and climbing
officials say the increase is not just
the result of more tests you see an
increasing positivity yeah you're
testing more but you're finding more
cases at a at a faster clip on Friday
the White House flagged 10 states with
the largest increases in test positivity
in all of them people below the age of
40 account for the largest number of
positive cases and as young people
increasingly test positive
some appear unfazed by the public health
risk gatherings pose but the virus can
have dire consequences for younger
people like 29 year old Ally Guidry who
was hospitalized with the corona virus
in May when she went to the hospital she
was only twenty weeks pregnant
she hung on long enough to do what she
had to do in order to give us Maddie Ali
died Thursday but her daughter Madeline
survived an emergency c-section and is
now in the neonatal ICU Ali's mom Denise
and her fiance Michael are urging people
not to take chances with the virus you
would hear about
the debts of the olden people and not a
29 year old that's healthy love you
family because it's not guarantee a Liga
dree is survived by her mother her
fiance her eight-year-old son Aiden and
now her daughter Madeline Madeline were
told weighs just about two pounds and is
in stable condition just last week the
CDC released a report saying pregnant
women are more likely to end up in the
hospital in the ICU and on a ventilator
because of the corona virus
Toni are rooting for baby Madeline there
Manny thank you very much